[Musique]
bonsoir james merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france avant la grève
c'est israël qui viennent donc de signer
un accord touristique permettant à leurs
citoyens respectifs ayant été vaccinés
contre le coc vide de voyager sans
restriction dans ces deux pays c'est la
solution selon vous pourriez vous s'il
vous plaît à répéter alors je disais
donc la grèce et israël j'espère que
vous en entendez bien voilà qui ont
signé cet accord sur le passeport
vaccinale ils pourront les grecs et les
israéliens voyager sans restriction ce
qu'ils se font vacciner contre le coc
vide
est ce que pour vous c'est aujourd'hui
la bonne solution
je pense que nous allons voir cela de
plus en plus au cours des années à venir
une bulle entre deux pays qui ont qui se
sont conformés aux procédures de
vaccination au niveau du pourcentage et
l'animation au sein des deux pays
personne qui se targue d'être
scientifique sans être qualifié d
opinion sur les vaccins le fait qu'ils
aient c'est qu'avec la progression de la
vaccination y aura ces bulles de plus en
plus donc effectivement il ya déjà une
ville avec hong kong et on parle
également du passeport vaccinale et je
pense que cela va être le chemin à
suivre
alors on l'a vu l'europe notamment est
très divisé sur le sujet notamment en
france où on est carrément réticents
enfin il faut dire qu'en même temps on
n'arrive pas vacciner beaucoup en ce
moment donc ça sera un débat dans un
deuxième temps sans vouloir être cynique
est-ce que selon vous on y viendra
nécessairement il faut bien faire des
pcr pour voyager vous en savez quelque
chose puisque vous avez effectué un jeu
précise plus de 140 vols à l'année
dernière je crois que vous êtes celui
qui est le plus voyagé sur la planète
apparemment et plus de 60 tests pcr
l'année dernière donc en gros est-ce que
forcément on y viendra à ce passeport
vaccinale comme on le fait aujourd'hui
avec les pcr 106 la façon dont les gens
voyagent beaucoup de personnes n'ont pas
peur des vols internationaux et je pense
que cette inquiétude va rester pendant
moins deux ans donc le niveau et du vol
international où l'art est pas pour cinq
ou six ans et j'ai constaté beaucoup de
changements au cours des douze mois
effectivement comment développer les
tests pcr les restrictions dans les
différents pays
j'espère lecanu d'ici à fin de l'été à
la fin de cette année les restrictions
seront assouplies et que on va retrouver
la souveraineté des frontières et que
les gens pourront à nouveau se dépasser
du en australie notamment au cours de
l'année passée j'avais moins de
restrictions et les villes
une dame allons entrer dans le pays où
un sortir est devenu quasiment
impossible quarantaine de deux semaines
en entrant ou sortant le contrôle des
frontières est vraiment très très poussé
les européens peuvent se fonder sur ce
que l'on fait en matière sanitaire
donc je pense que les vols domestiques
seront bien plus importants à dans
l'avenir proche lui mais je pense qu'il
y aura toujours des contrôles aux
frontières a qui pourrait même continuer
au cours des années suivantes
les être certain de qui rentrent sur le
territoire vous parlez du scepticisme
autour des vaccins et c'est vrai qu'en
france il y en a un réel même s'il tend
à régresser la part des français qui ne
souhaite pas se faire vacciner en tout
cas qui sont très sceptiques et quand
même encore importante
clairement vous le professionnel du
tourisme vous pensez qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui sont réticents à voyager qui
le sauront même une fois vacciner ça
reste du domaine du possible qu'il y ait
vraiment un avant et un après si l'on
peut dire mais je ne suis pas un
scientifique et tout le monde a son
opinion sur les vaccins ce qui selon lui
ceux qui sont mauvais et dont je ne peux
pas vraiment mettre ma pierre à
l'édifice
je n'ai pas vraiment la compétence je
pense que nous en sommes à un stade où
beaucoup de personnes vivent confinés
depuis longtemps et instruments il ne
semble pas devoir à disparaître avant
longtemps
quelque chose doit changer pour moi à
moins que les gens souhaitent vivre
comme ça pour toujours alors le vaccin
c'est le seul moyen d'avancer les
experts scientifiques parlent également
de paracétamol d'autres médicaments
on les accepte je ne vois pas pourquoi
est ce que les vaccins soirée
inacceptable tu me manques que les
experts médicaux les soutiennent pour
moi il n'y a pas d'autre solution
il ya un an oui nous a fait penser que
dans 2 3 secondes de confinement
réussirez à arrêter la contamination
mais ça n'est pas comme ça que c'est
arrivé quelque chose doit changer et
pour moi c'est de vaccins on l'a dit
vous avez fait donc 140 vols c'est
beaucoup l'année dernière est ce qu'il
ya des pays où la gestion de la crise du
cornât virus nous a frappés est ce que
c'est vraiment différent en fonction de
là où on voyage dans le monde au niveau
des restrictions des libertés
individuelles est ce que ça varie
beaucoup et il est très intéressant de
voir la façon dont les pays ont évolué
au cours du processus également voyagé
dans certains pays ou ont testé à
l'arrivée ce qui ne marchait pas du tout
donc ça a été vraiment un processus en
grand huit certains pays ont bien géré
et que d'autres certains ont dit qu'on
doit soutenir les économies on doit
soutenir les commerces certains pays ou
un système sanitaire très solide
je suis moi-même un économiste et on ne
peut pas se fier que à la sainteté il
faut adopter des approches pragmatiques
face à la situation
je me suis rendu organes à l'année
dernière pour le travail il y avait des
tests de 15 minutes à l'arrivée c'est
que j'ai également un test pcr je suis
aux états unis et obtenir tous les états
uns font différemment à la essaie de se
rouvrir au tourisme et demande également
de test pcr
ainsi qu'une quarantaine de trois jours
et adressé hier à la sortie une
quarantaine de deux semaines où une
quarantaine en hôtel par exemple le
royaume visages le roi enis n'était pas
tenable pour des gens qui veulent faire
des séjours très très court de deux ou
trois jours par exemple
donc je pense que certains pays approche
adoptée nous approche plus réaliste pc à
l'entrée paix sert à la sortie et une
quarantaine dont on peut sortir après un
test négatif la meilleure approche pour
moi consiste à garder autant que le type
d'économie verte et je pense que le
tourisme aura beaucoup souffrir pendant
un certain temps mais j'espère que plus
tard cette année nous ferons changement
vers un tourisme régional et domestiques
il ya en france où le temps les autres
et le pays on pouvait se dire rendre les
vacances en france passé de paris a
aussi de la france est un peu ennuyant
je pourrais faire ça à n'importe quel
moment alors que se rendre à bali par
exemple ça c'est vraiment intéressant
maintenant on n'a plus cette possibilité
marié secret finement je pense que
n'importe qui serait très heureux de
pouvoir aller simplement à la plage ne
serait ce que pour un week end dans le
même temps ça devient intéressant parce
que c'est une expérience qu'on a plus
donc peut-être que cette forme de
tourisme va se développer c'est un
nombre de gens pourront plus en profiter
en tout cas il est certain que les
frontières vraiment rester fermés au
moins jusqu'à l'année prochaine cela
aura une influence sur les habitudes
merci beaucoup de jeunes ça squeeze
fondateur de rely des swaps de nous
avoir apporté votre analyse merci à vous